it has been a while since i filmed a
minimalism video so today i wanted to
share with you 15 items that i only own
one of as well as 10 common items that i
do not own please know though that i am
not telling you not to own these things
if you find value in some of these items
then by all means keep them really i'm
sharing this because i know that when i
started our minimalism journey i knew
what i wanted wanted less clutter more
peace of mind and i wanted to sell a lot
of our things to get out of debt but i
didn't know the how and so i looked to a
lot of these decluttering videos to kind
of get ideas and think hmm
maybe i could go without that and so
that's kind of what this video is about
today hopefully it will be helpful for
you but please just take it with a grain
of salt you don't have to get rid of any
of these items if you find them valuable
and they bring joy to your life as
always if you find this video helpful
please give it a thumbs up to help
support my channel if not then at least
give me some feedback in the comments so
that i know what to work on and stick
around for the very last one because
that item that we do not own really
truly changed a lot of things in our
life so the first item that i own one of
is a purse and i know some women
probably don't even have a purse but i
included this in the list because i used
to have several purses i had black purse
big purses small purses backpack purses
or i guess i don't know what you call
those little just backpack bags whatever
i had a lot of different bags different
colors different sizes i mean i'm just
telling you i had an assortment to match
each of my outfits and i drove without
my license on many occasions because i
kept forgetting to switch my wallet from
one purse to the other and then i
realized why am i doing all this so i
got rid of all of them but one i now
only have one purse it's a cross body
bag it's kind of small from what i used
to have but it fits my phone perfectly
it fits my wallet my keys it really is
the one that i really liked the best
that was the most versatile and it just
works for me so now the only bag that i
have is my favorite bag the next item
that i only own one of is really kind of
an assortment of items and this is
makeup and i include that on the list
even though i know that some people
probably don't even have makeup because
i was one that had this big chest of
makeup that like opens up that has like
little drawers that pull out and i had
all sorts of eye shadows and contouring
things and fake lashes and liners and i
mean i had the stuff okay i love makeup
but now i've just found that i like
having the one item that works for me
that's very minimal and i realized that
i had all sorts of things that i didn't
even use like i rarely used eye
eyeshadow and i had all sorts of
different kinds of palettes so now
everything that i have fits in one
little pouch and it's actually like a
little travel size so i can take it
anywhere like for example we're gonna
see my in-laws this weekend i can just
grab my little pouch and take it with me
so everything that i have is my favorite
the next item on the list is sneakers
slash tennis shoes workout shoes
whatever you call them
i had several of these types of shoes
and i realized that i was wearing one
because it was the most comfortable but
i had others just in case these get
ruined and then i have to use the other
pair
and i decided i was going to get rid of
these just in case items i had the one
pair of shoes that i feel really
comfortable in that are versatile
because they're black they work with any
kind of color that i'm wearing and i
kept this one pair and actually i've
been keeping them for about two years
now and i haven't needed my just in case
shoes the next item on the list is heels
now i love femininity i love to feel
like a princess and wear dresses and
heels and all sorts of things that make
me just dressed up and there's nothing
wrong with that but i had like 30 pairs
of high heels you guys i had a problem i
had an assortment of prom dresses gala
style dresses and i
realized that i wasn't wearing any of
these things and neither were they
comfortable actually so now i have one
pair of black heels their classic mary
jane pump style shoe that i can dance
for hours in and feel comfortable i can
wear in different types of situations
because they're just so versatile
one pair is all i need i don't need 30
pairs of high heels the next item on the
list is one winter hat
and i'm not really a big winter hat kind
of a person i know that some people have
like this the beanies and different
colors of beanies and stuff like that
for me if i'm wearing a winter hat it's
because it's my i don't care what the
weather is i'm going outside hat and i
actually use this to work in this house
when we were building it in winter and
it actually has paint stains on it
because
it was below freezing but yet my ears
were nice and warm and toasty as we were
working and laying siding and caulking
and all those sorts of things so for me
this hat is more of a
weather you are not going to stop me
kind of a hat rather than a statement
piece i don't really wear it to go out
so one hat is really all that i need and
actually now that i think about it i
could just steal my husband's beanies
for that purpose
the next item on the list is a pair of
gloves and i actually thrifted these a
few years ago for like five dollars not
realizing that they're coach but i
bought these because they're black
they're versatile they keep my hands
nice and toasty and for me where i live
i definitely want gloves because it does
get below freezing but really one pair
is all that i need i don't need more
than that the next item that i have one
of is a wallet and i know that a lot of
people only have one wallet anyway but i
wanted to show you mine because it's
very minimal it keeps my cards my
entrance cards it has a slot in the
middle where i can put cash in and this
is truly all that i need as far as a
wallet goes i like that it makes it just
so easy to move anywhere that i need or
if i want to go without carrying a purse
i can just stick it in my pocket because
it's so small kind of going along with
that i only have one credit card and i
know it's kind of typical for a lot of
people to have several credit cards
because they can get like the points and
rewards and all those sorts of things
and i personally actually did have
several credit cards i didn't really
notice that they were doing anything for
me so i cancelled all but one i don't
feel like i need any more than that and
if anything it's like less to really
think about like oh did i pay that bill
or not and i know you got like the auto
pays and things like that but it's less
to think about less to worry about i
personally didn't really notice much of
a change in my credit score i don't feel
like i need it so for me one is all that
i need next up sunglasses i'm not a big
sunglass kind of a person i do like to
have them when i'm driving because i
drive a lot i'm a home nurse and so for
me just visibility is very important
when i'm driving but that pair lives in
my vehicle and that's really all that i
use it for so one is all i need the next
item on the list is workout leggings and
i had several kinds of leggings i had
like the ones with designs on the side
and different colors and long ones and
short ones and
i don't need that many first of all i
wash laundry almost every day so i found
that one black pair is enough for me
next up is shorts i really i don't love
shorts but i use these kind of as my
workout short swimming shorts
all purpose really because they have
this kind of thin material that dries
quickly so just kind of a versatile
piece
next up is dress pant i only have one
black dress pant i actually did have
several dress pants but for me i'm just
a dress kind of a girl i like skirts and
dresses so one dress pant that is black
that fits with different things is all
that i need i also like that it's
high-waisted and it's a thin material so
i love it in the summer because it's
just it doesn't feel hot but in the
winter i can put my leggings underneath
and just be so warm and toasty and
nobody would ever know next up on the
list is a summer hat and truly i only
wear this about one or two times a year
when we go to the beach so if we were
talking about how much i use it some
people could probably say that i
shouldn't own it but you know what i
like it i think it's pretty i feel good
when i'm wearing it and so for me it's
okay to keep this even though i only
wear it a couple of times throughout the
year but that being said because i don't
wear hats often i don't need more than
one i can only justify having one for
myself next up on the list is a hair
scrunchie so i actually have this brand
it's by teletize and i tried this
because i have long hair and my hair
would always hurt when putting it up in
a ponytail so i heard about this brand
people were raving about it and i tried
it to see if it would actually keep my
ponytail up without hurting my hair and
actually i was surprised that it did i
did like the way that it held my hair up
this is the only scrunchie that i have
now and it works perfectly for me if
they stretch out i can just put it in
hot water and it kind of like shrinks
back to size so
now i don't have all sorts of the black
hair ties i can just use the one
and the last item on this list that i
only own one of is an umbrella and this
is actually one that i'd like your
advice on so to give you some backstory
my husband and i we kind of both come
from the country from mexico and he was
kind of raised that even if it's raining
you go out and you work and
when he was young he had to work before
he went to school and then after school
now i was young i didn't really have
that experience um but when we got
married he just kind of instilled in to
me that even if it rained it didn't
matter he was going out and working
outside and and i liked that i actually
liked that because
i kind of grew up with this oh it's
raining i can't go outside i can't do
the things that i would do if it's not
raining and
so i started to adopt that and truly
where we live we don't have a garage we
just we go out we take the kids in the
vehicle if we get wet we get wet i mean
don't get me wrong they have rain boots
and they have rain jackets but for me
i don't own rain boots or rain jackets
and you know what if i get wet i get wet
it's okay so i actually rarely use the
umbrella and i'd kind of like for our
kids to
not be afraid of the elements like be
well dressed and be prepared but it's
okay if it's raining go out go have fun
go do work go do whatever it is that
you're gonna go do so i don't know i'm
kind of thinking of actually
decluttering the umbrella what do you
think should we declutter it is that
actually a necessity what's your point
of view on this okay i need to move on
with this list because i feel like i'm
ranting on forever but now moving on to
the items that i don't own
first up pajamas i am probably gonna
drive some elegant women out there crazy
because i don't own pajamas for a while
i was using a slip that i used under my
dresses as my pajama and then that had
seen better days it was time to let it
go
and i just never replaced it you know
what if i wear a t-shirt i wear a
t-shirt it's fine i think confidence
looks much better on a person than what
you own and what you're actually wearing
on the exterior so for me
i don't feel like i need pajamas i'm
okay
next item that i do not own is swimsuits
so i mentioned that i have one pair of
shorts and it's like quick drying
material i realized that i had several
swimsuits and
i don't like swimming i would go to the
beach and never get in the beach i'm
more of a beach goer i'd like to walk on
the beach bike read books collect shells
that sort of thing but i never really
got in the water i don't like it i mean
i'll do it but i don't enjoy it so i
don't really need swimsuits if i'm not
swimming my pair of shorts if i'm
actually going to go swimming will do
just fine next up on the list is belts i
actually did have several belts i had
like brown belts and black belts but now
i have high-waisted jeans they fit me
just fine i don't feel like i need to
pull or hold anything up and i did have
like the waist belts that would just
kind of be more figure flattering with
dresses and shirts and things like that
but i now find that i like more of a
simple style of dress now the next item
on the list is kindles tablets e-readers
and that sort of a thing it's not an
item that i wouldn't necessarily have
because i actually do really enjoy
reading and my husband and i would go to
bed at the same time and he wakes up at
four every morning and i i don't think
that he would enjoy if i'm sleeping late
at night with the light on reading my
books that just wouldn't be nice so it's
not something that i wouldn't own i
would probably enjoy it i like reading
but it's not something that i ever
really see myself spending the money on
at least not now another item that i do
not own is a hairbrush or a comb so when
i was in high school i used to dye my
hair all the time straighten my hair
curl my hair i used to do so many
horrible things to it and it was super
frizzy it was bad you guys i would just
walk outside on a humid day and i could
just i could feel it lifting and i
decided i was fed up i was done i was
gonna stop curling it stop ironing it
and i chopped it off to my shoulders and
when i did that i didn't need a comb or
a brush anymore because i just i started
using my hands and as it started to grow
out i just got used to just brushing it
out with my hands and if it ever got
kind of tangly then i would put a little
bit of oil and that's it so i don't even
know where to tell you where my comb and
my hairbrush went so
yeah i haven't had one of those in years
also i don't know if it's weird but if i
need to part my hair i just use whatever
i have on hand like a bobby pin or my
tweezers or my grooming scissors is that
weird the next item i don't own is nail
polish and this one again stamped
because i had a huge assortment of nail
polish you guys when i was in high
school i'm telling you i had a vanity
problem i mean i still need to work on
that i need to work on a lot of things
i'm a work in progress but i used to
like put little stickers on them and
gems on them and put little little like
lines and polka dots i had different
styled nails all the time i had like the
gel set and i realized that i didn't
need all of that i remember one lunch
season i decided i was going to fast my
vanity and get rid of all but two nail
polishes i allowed myself one for my
nails and one for my feet and you know
what after that process it actually hurt
me it was hard it was so hard because it
was like an addiction for me every every
couple of days i would paint my nails
and i stopped and i realized
i don't need it anymore you know what i
don't think that people really care
about what my nails look like anyway and
if anything it's something less to worry
about so yeah i haven't had nail polish
in a couple years and i don't miss it
the next item that i don't own is kind
of an assortment of things that i don't
own and it's like scented lotion scented
candles perfumes for the home body
perfume uh laundry boot scent booster
all those sort of scented items i've
mentioned in a previous video that i had
so many bath and body works lotions and
candles and i had the little wax burners
and things like that i had a lot of
scented items in the home until i
realized that these things have
chemicals called endocrine disruptors
and what these things do is they
actually harm your body's natural
processes and they have been linked to
cancer and for individuals with cancer
there is worry that these could actually
cause worsening of the condition
so just kind of do your research on
scented items they are horrible things
they're really toxic for you they're not
things that you really want to be
breathing in so what i did is i got rid
of all those sorts of things now if i
ever want perfume
essential oils is what i use but i do
not use those sorts of things in my
house and if anything what i did is
bring in more plants specifically air
purifying plants because these clean the
air nasa actually recommends that you
have one air purifying plant per every
100 square feet you have in your home so
i started to bring in more plants in the
home like the san severia or the snake
plant pothos just different plants that
clean the air and just allow my home to
have
healthy air to breathe the next item
that i don't own is conditioner like
hair conditioner and so as i started to
learn about scented items and scented
lotions and perfumes and that sort of
thing it kind of brought me the question
well what else is toxic in my home and
believe me there was a huge list of
things that i slowly started to get rid
of as my eyes were just opened up and
one of the things that i learned about
was the toxic chemicals that are often
placed in shampoos and conditioners and
i learned about coconut oil oh there's
gotta be a bajillion uses for coconut
oil but i started using it as a hair
conditioner basically what i do is i use
it as a hair mask before i shampoo and
this is not an everyday thing it's
really once i start to see my hair kind
of getting dry i put it on my hair and
my scalp as a mask about 30 minutes
before i go into the shower and then i
shampoo like normally and this leaves my
hair feeling soft i have not really
needed conditioners anymore also another
thing that i just thought of that is not
included on the list but i don't have
teeth whiteners because coconut oil is
also good for oil pulling basically i
used to have teeth whiteners which were
horrible for your teeth and they made my
teeth hurt actually and now what i do is
i just kind of swish around coconut oil
in my mouth if you want to add baking
soda even better and it makes your teeth
white
coconut oil has a bajillion uses guys
you don't need teeth whiteners the next
item on the list is an assortment again
it's all sorts of skin paraphernalia
like toners and skin cleansers and
anti-aging things and shaving creams all
those sorts of things i do not use any
of those if anything i have minimized so
much because now i just use a coconut
oil bar soap to wash my face and if my
skin is dry i just kind of follow up
with just a dab of coconut oil it does
it for me because i never really noticed
any of those other things doing magical
things for me and believe me i was at
the age of 20 buying anti-aging serums
and things like that that
i didn't need
and lastly but certainly not least the
number one item that really changed a
lot of things for us when we decluttered
it is the television i never really
liked the tv anyway but when my husband
decided that we were gonna get rid of
the tv
i was all for it let me give you the
back story my husband and i have been
very much in love from the very
beginning we are super cheesy we are
very happy couple but we did have a
problem especially as newlyweds really
as newlyweds um is that he was very much
addicted to video games he'll be the
first person to admit it i would come
home from work i'm a nurse so 12 hour
shifts and
when i would arrive he would be on the
screen playing his video game you guys
he wouldn't even turn to look at me to
say hello how are you how was your day
he would keep on playing uh-huh yes
honey
he wouldn't join me at the dinner table
because he had to finish that level
sometimes i'd go to bed at night and he
would be playing that game because he he
just had to get to that one last level
it was an addiction it was a true
addiction and when i got pregnant with
our first child something just changed
within him it was like he realized that
we had a problem and that it was not
okay don't get me wrong he is an amazing
amazing man who serves me he gets up in
the morning and makes me breakfast even
though he gets up at four in the morning
i mean he is truly serving me and and
does care for me however this one thing
had to change and he was willing to
change that
and so i was surprised when one day he
calls me up and he says
get rid of that tv sell it donate it
whatever i don't want it in the house
i've gotten rid of the console i don't
want it anymore i just about wanted to
cry that day i was like
okay
i'm not going to give you time to change
your mind about it we're getting rid of
it
and i was surprised when after i got rid
of it i thought i thought there would be
like this morning period where he would
be like what am i gonna do and and no
actually none of that when we started
this minimalist journey i never really
forced him to get rid of anything i
didn't make him you got to get rid of
these things um i started to get rid of
my own things and as i did that i
started to see changes in him he started
to see that we could work together
towards our goals and that kind of also
at the same time started to
impact our financial goals this is when
we started to know about dave ramsey and
the fire movement and we started to
really work hard on our goals our mutual
goals so instead of having the tv it
wasn't this morning period we now had
time to work together towards our future
and
matter of fact we had a lot of work to
do because we built this house i mean
our names are written in the studs we
did this and we did this together and i
think in huge part because we didn't
have this tv as a distraction we now
have the time to work more but for a
greater purpose for something together
in unity now tv may not be an addiction
for you that is okay if you have this
this item but for us it was causing
problems and so he decided to get rid of
it nail it kind of like i got rid of my
nail polish because it was a problem for
me i got rid of my prom dresses because
that was a problem for me so really see
the items that are not helping you get
to where you want to be keep the items
that are helping you towards that goal
if you have for example tools for
construction or mechanic tools and and
that's going to help you get to where
you want to be keep those don't get rid
of those but any items that you have
that are holding you back from achieving
your goals from achieving your dreams
those are really the items that you
should be tackling so it really doesn't
matter if you have one less spoon or one
less fork
because there's something bigger that
you know that you need to be
decluttering so my hope for all of this
is not that you really look at
individual items
more so that you look at your life in
entirety what kind of a life do you want
to have and what kind of items do you
picture yourself having with that ideal
life and what items are helping you get
to that life and what items are
hindering you from getting to that point
so just kind of take a look at those
hopefully this list has been helpful for
you please know this is not something
that you have to get rid of all those
things it's just meant as an idea
hopefully some inspiration i hope it's
been enjoyable i thank you for your time
and i can't wait to hear from you in the
comments and let me know about that
umbrella thing i really want to know
what you think so thank you for your
time i can't wait to hear from you until
next time
bye